الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما
رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله
في النار اما بعد
فيقول الله
سبحانه وتعالى
واذ قال موسى لفتاه لا ابرح
ابلغ مجمع البحرين
او امضي حقبا
قول موسى عليه السلام هذا
لخادمه
وتابعه وطالبه كان يقوم ويخدم
موسى عليه السلام ويقوم بحاجته
وكان يتعلم منه يوشع ابن نون
عليه السلام الذي جعل نبيا بعد وفاه موسى
واخيه هارون
موسى عليه السلام قال لفتاه لا ابرح اي لن
ازال مستمرا في سفرنا هذا حتى ابلغ مجمع
البحرين
او امضي حقبا
حقبه يعني عشرات رات السنين مستمر ان شاء
الله 100 سنه لمني ابلغ مجمع البحرين
للقاء الخضر عليه السلام
وقد اخرج الامام الحافظ البخاري في صحيحه
في اسناده عن ابن عباس ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال قام نبي الله موسى عليه
السلام خطيبا في بني اسرائيل
فسئل عن اعلم اهل الارض فقال انا
فعاتبه الله اذ لم يرد العلم اليه اي لم
يقل الله اعلم
فامره ان يسير
وان ياخذ حوتا سمكه في مكتل في سله وفي
وان يمضي متجها الى مجمع البحر
قال بعض المفسرين
مجمع البحرين
اي حيث يجتمع بحر الروم وبحر فارس لكن هذا
يستبعد
لان بحر الروم وبحر فارس لا يجتمعان
لكن الراجح لا نعلم نعلم
هذه البحرين
لكن نعلم م ان الله امره ان يتجه ان يتجه
الى مجمع البحرين حي الله بحرين ما بنعرف
لكن هذا فيه دلاله على اجتماع
موسى والخضر
هذا اجتماع بحرين بحر من العلم من علوم
الله الشرعيه وبحر من علوم الله الكونيه
القدريه الخضر عليه السلام
فمضى
فبينما هما نائمان
اذ احيا الله هذه السمكه
واتخذ هذا الحوت في البحر سبيله
وجعل الله سبحانه وتعالى سبيله في البحر
سربا
يعني يمشي في الميه وما يتلائم الميه من
وراه شوف بس سمكه مشت ظلت الميه مثل ما هي
صحي يوشع النون شاف السمكه رايحه مشت في
البحر وما تلائم البحر من بعده فاتخذ
سبيله في البحر سربا
فموسى عليه السلام صحي وانساه الشيطان ان
يذكر هذه الحادثه لموسى
فجاوز
جاوز المكان الذي كتب الله
ف اصابهما النصب
فيقول الله عز وجل حكايه عن موسى فلما
جاوز
قال لفتاه اتنا غداءنا لقد لقينا من سفر
من سفرنا هذا نصبا يعني تعبا شديدا وراهقا
فهنا تذكر يوشعب النون وقال له ارايت اذ
اوينا الى الصخره فاني نسيت الحوت وما
انسانيه الا الشيطان ان اذكره واتخذ سبيله
في البحر عجبا
بالنسبه لل للسمكه كان سبيله سربا
وبالنسبه ليوشع النون كان سبيله عجبا شيء
عجيب
قال ذلك ما كنا نبغي
فارتدا على اثارهما قصصا فوجدا عبدا من
عبادنا اتيناه رحمه من علم من عندنا
وعلمناه من لدنا علما قال له موسى هل
اتبعك على ان تعلمني مما علمت رشده
قال انك لن تستطيع طيع معي صبرا
وكيف تصبر على ما لم تحط به خبرا
قال ستجدني ان شاء الله صابرا ولا اعصي لك
امرا
قال فان اتبعتني فلا تسالني عن شيء حتى
احدث لك منه ذكر فانطلق
الله سبحانه وتعالى tellsory
صحيحن عباس
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الكهف
موسى عليه السلام
بني اسرائيل
مو عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى موسى عليه السلام
يوشعن
هارون بني اسرائيل
and
‏take
kind of lether baset baset woven
and to travel towards the place where
the two seas meet
which two seas we don't know and it
doesn't matter
but this is very symbolic that Allah
chose the place where the two seas meet
physically
موسى الخضر
موسى عليه السلام الخضر
and areysical
me
and
tell them this
‏place
الخضر
and go
and
fall asleep take as peopleav
whileleep the life
الله سبحانه وتعالى
would come back together
went into the
tunnel where this fish had swam remained
a mirage almost like
‏and
w up
wasleurb
him
to wake up asleep because propets their
body sleeps but their hearts are always
awake.
‏and
up could
عليه up
makes him for aboutish
and about to tell
musa wakes
‏needun
and now
and say the for to tell you about say
this is exactly what we were waiting for
and so they took their tracks back and
they found there a man whom Allah
describes
اتيناه رحمه اي نبوه
من عندنا وعلمناه من لدنا علما اي علما
عظيما
لا يملكه حتى موسى عليه السلام لا يحفظ
هذا العلم اختصر
بهذا العلم
انو
الخضر موسى عليه
الخضر
out
says
you can't me because you will not be
able to be patientsing
the things that you will see you're not
equ for that can you be patient andserve
the things
‏said you will findent
and are traitud
a student is not going to understand
everything that teacher teaches him
there is a point where you have to trust
the teacher and you have to take it
exactly as the teacher tells you a
patient
‏and
say you can me under one
you are not to ask debate me on anything
un
you to you first you wait for me to
otherwi
don't ask me any
فانطلقا
and
they areing down the beide
the
tak onto a ship of merchants
and these merchants are you know they're
not well off ‏They are just making ends
meat. It's clear that they are going
through tough times, but they are good
at heart and good willed. And some say
that they recognized
and they took them for free
and as they sailed out and side of land
and they were to far to go back. الخضر
puts in the boat.
And so
is watching that he just put a hole
right in the hole and water now is
coming into thisat
and they are scing trying to keep this
flat.
موسى عليه السلام
[Silence]
لقد جئت شيئا امرا يعني شيئا منكرا
قال الم اقل انك لن تستطيع معي صبر
قال لا تؤاخذني بما نسيت ولا ترهقني من
امري عسرا فانطلقا حتى اذا لقي غلاما
فقتله
لقي غلاما يلعب مع الغلمان
وجاء هنا بالفاء للدلاله على
متابعه ما بعدها لما قبلها على الفو لقي
غلاما قال له تعال اخذه وذبحه بالسكين
وفي بعض الروايات اخذ راسه فاقتلع
ما هذا؟
قال اقتلت نفسا زكيه بغير نفس لقد جئت
شيئا نكر
قال الم اقل
انك لن تستطيع معي صبرا
موسى عليه
‏outing
some
and some narrations the most
the cutest the most
handsome of these young men
are
in age
takes him and kills him on the spot
and
عليه السلام
مو عليه السلام
inoc
‏I not tell you
would not be able to take
and you would not be able to be
patientsing what I do.
موسى عليه السلامخضر
[Silence]
عليه
‏Musa comes because
wasware
as
by Allah and
has been where is
so
مو عليه السلام
about
anything again
ag
take you
on himself not
andarn from this that do not place
kindri
upon your
‏If you place
you willigated toulf
you will be tre by as you have agreed
for him to treat you you will be tre by
others as you have agreed for them to
treat you and so they continue in this
journey
and now they come into
‏a city or a town
and they hungry theyve been traveling in
tatters and they seek to be taken in as
guest
in this town and the people of this town
are such lousy
honorless people
they are people that have so little
honor and so little digity that they
refus
‏and
they are walking through to the
outskirts of this and they find this old
wall. Now many of uscially those of us
who have been born in the west and in
this new era of this new kind of cement
jungle. ‏It's hard for us to imagine the
way things were back then. But people
didn't usually build walls out of bricks
and so forth. People would build walls
and they would build walls between
pieces of land out of stones. They would
collect all the rocks and stones in
their piece of land and they would stack
them strategically
so that these stones would act as a
wall.
‏by take not me to out
the place
and
they come by
and find this wall
tole over so الخضر عليه السلام he stops
rolls up sleeves
‏and
he just makes a comment
was in the
rebild
could use as
he
لو شئت لاتخذت عليه اجرا قال هذا فراق
بيني وبينك
before you putting theirat now got
peopleay them by rebuilding theirity
‏you
anyore not based on what I told you but
based on the restrictions you placed on
yourself but before you go I will
explain to you everything that you just
saw
he explains to him that group of men the
sailor
‏un
toiling
that is notorious for confat
that he likes. He has a sickness he
likes to collect boats and if he sees
one he will take it. ‏How does he take
it? Oh, you know this boat doesn't have
a right to be you have to pay certain
money or whatever it is the way that
governments use to and bucies to take
people's land and money. It's a old
tail. And so
in order for
me to get them to take their boat and go
home because that would devat their
livelood.
‏I put just enough damage on this boat
to keep it for them without sinking
them, but to make it to where the king
would overlook this boat to not take it.
And as for that young boy,
that young boy is going to grow up and
become a wicked and evil man.
‏But his par are so smitten by this boy
that he will lead them into disbelief
and they will lose their life in this
world and in the here because of their
unbled love for this child.
And so by Allah's command I took this
child's life and
has planned to give them another child.
‏in his place will be a rightous man and
willad them inad to parad
and as for the wall that wall actually
belonged to two orphans
and underneath that wall their for and
in some versions of this narration their
fora had buried a treasure for them
under this wall and as
‏is not
they will grow up uncover that
if I would have allowed that wall to
fall over the people would have come to
rebuild it they would dig its
foundations and find the treasure and
take it for themselves. And weve already
seen the kind of people that the
inhabitants of this town are.
‏And so none of these things that I did
my own every things الله himself commوي
ذلك
that this is the interpretation
and this is the end resultاوي
ما يؤول اليه الشيء اي هذه عاقبه وحقيقه
حقيقه ما قد رايت مني
الله سبحانه وتعالى
people
صلى الله عليه
الخضر اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي
ولكم ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو
الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله
الحمد لله حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا فيه
حمدا يوافي نعمه ويكافئ مزيده
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
تاكيدا بعد تاكيد لبيان مقام التوحيد
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وخليله وامينه على وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه
اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى حكايه عن الخضر مع موسى
ذلك تاويل ما لم اسطع تستطع عليه صبرا
والله عز وجل قص علينا هذه القصه العظيمه
هذه القصه العظيمه من اجل ان يتفكر المرء
في احوال حياته وان يحسن ظنه بالله وان
يعترض على قدر الله وانما
يقول كما امر رسول الله صلى الله عيه عليه
وسلم قدر الله وما شاء فعل فان لو تفتح
عمل الشيطان الله
makes this is
to our
backing
our lives
‏ill because
our
byى
and as are
‏anything
that happ to us will make user
will give usorten
our
المؤمن ان امره كله له خير ان اصابه ان
اصاب اصابته سراء شكر فكان خيرا له وان
اصابته ضراء صبر فكان خيرا له اللهم صل
على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما
باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا وكفر عنا سيئاتنا وتوفنا مع
الابرار ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك
ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه انك لا تخلف
الميعاد اللهم اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار ربنا هب لنا
من ازواجنا وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا
للمتقين اماما اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشركين وافضح
النفاق والمنافقين اللهم عليك باعدائك
اعداء الدين اللهم دمر عل اللهم دمرهم
تدميرا اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من شرورهم
ونجعلك في نحورهم اللهم اجعل تدبيرهم
تدميرهم يا رب العالمين اللهم امين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووادوا
‏enting
all are not until the of isely toacing
ourers andet are with the shoulders and
feet of our two nebors use the lines are
in the caret as a guide but
that your shoulders andet
‏an
side and women
exactly the way if ours
willignos
undercut
صلوا صلاه مودع الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
انا
اعطيناك
الكوثر فصل لربك وانحر
ان شانئك هو الابتر
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حم حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
اذا جاء
نصر الله والفتح
ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره انه كان توابا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله
সার அஸலாமு அலைக்கும்
ரயன்ஷ
அல்லாஹ
830ஹல
மலன்
மலை
இஷly
জাজাকল্লাহলাম السلام عليكم
[Silence]
السلام
Š